perhaps a life of solitude awaited me
i'd die alone my cats would feast on my
eyeballs
holy [ __ ]
their son alcove he goes to my uni
why was he walking towards me what a
specimen
lustrous facial hair indicating rurality
while maintaining boy next door
adorableness
with eyebrows you could hang on to
was it fate bringing us together destiny
kismet there was no denying this
was a sign
where'd he go
[Music]
hi um
i'm looking for a boy uh a man uh he
gave me this
medium built radiant sad eyes you can
swim in could you kindly direct me to
his
whereabouts you've got your brother to
hand out the flyers i thought we might
reel in a thirsty [ __ ] with a shred of
talent
wait is he here to audition or what no
no you
you went to abigail's primary school you
played guitar in the talent show what
you were good
no yeah yeah no you were really good
until you puked all over the year sixes
in the front row
not my finest hour i remember you
you're siren you got expelled for
selling school furniture
fair elite is i oh so hang on you are a
guitarist she's a guitarist
she's a guitarist play something play
something
um uh i don't play i just teach you
you've got a play to teach i don't
perform
my nervy disposition induces diary and
vomiting
ew
i just teach okay i just ate
an unsettling encounter no doubt
you